ich kann mir nicht erklären wieso man
dieses video material nicht ausgewertet
hat ist es inkompetenz oder möchte man
es nicht und ich weiß nicht welche
erkenntnisse mehr angst macht wie kann
es sein dass ein polizeihubschrauber
eine halbe stunde nach der tat über
kesselstadt kreist und ihn über zwei
stunden lang nicht die adresse des
täters hauses zu überwachung genannt
wird
zur ausstellungs freedos in frankfurt
komme am eröffnungstag viele angehörige
der opfer des rassistischen anschlags
von hahn
[Musik]
und die von oury jalloh oury jallohs
bruder hier rechts ist eigens aus afrika
reißt er will erfahren was die
unabhängige rechercheagentur forensik
architecture über den tod seines bruders
ermittelt hat oury jalloh verbrannte
2005 in dessau in einer gewahrsamszelle
der polizei
schock trauer auch im februar 2020 in
hameln ein rechts terrorist ermordete
neun junge menschen nur weil er der
ansicht war sie seien keine deutschen
ihre angehörigen sind dankbar dass die
unabhängige rechercheagentur forensik
architekt nun einige der offenen fragen
wissenschaftlich untersucht hat three
doors drei türen eine davon meint den
notausgängen der rena war denn der tat
nacht verschlossen war
hansa-coach und zeitmesser chemie wurden
in der arena war erschossen
forensik architektur und ihre schwester
agentur forensik haben unter anderem
videomaterial
ermittlungsakten und zeugenaussagen
ausgewertet und wissenschaftlich
analysiert zum verschlossenen notausgang
zeigen sie ihre ergebnisse auch in einem
video zum hintergrund überlebende hatten
berichtet dass sie in der arena war
nicht zum notausgang gelaufen sein
sondern aus verzweiflung in eine ecke
der bar weil alle gewusst hätten dass
der notausgang zu sein
es gibt mehrere zeugenaussagen wonach es
einen deal des barbesitzers mit der
polizei gegeben habe um razzien zu
erleichtern deswegen sei der notausgang
schon lange verschlossen gewesen die
polizei habe das gewusst die weiß dass
gegenüber dem zdf zurück
[Musik]
durch die polizei er geht niemals eine
weisung oder aufforderung notausgänge zu
verschließen oder auf andere weise zu
versperren im gegenteil werden bei
erkennen derartiger verstöße umgehend
die zuständigen fachdienststellen von
uns informiert
umgehend informiert im tatort bericht
nach dem anschlag hat die polizei
verschlossenen türen in der rheder bar
fest ohne konsequenzen es sieben monate
später leitete die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittlungen ein nachdem angehörige
anzeige erstattet hatten diese
ermittlungen wurden letztes jahr beendet
im august 2021 stellte die hanauer
staatsanwaltschaft das strafverfahren
bezüglich des notausgangs ein und
behauptete nicht mit hinreichender
sicherheit davon ausgegangen werden kann
dass den opfern durch einen
unverschlossenen notausgang die flucht
geglückt wäre wir haben ihre pfade
gespiegelt um zu sehen was passieren
würde wenn sie mit der exakt gleichen
geschwindigkeit auf den notausgang
zuliefen wenn wir dieses hypothetisches
szenario animieren wird deutlich wäre
die gruppe statt in die hintere ecke der
bar mit der gleichen geschwindigkeit in
richtung des notausgangs gelaufen
so wären zu dem zeitpunkt an dem der
täter die bar betritt
vier der fünf person vollständig
außerhalb seines sichtfeldes gewesen die
fünfte person wäre dabei acht meter vom
täter entfernt und nur teilweise und für
einen sekundenbruchteil in seinem
sichtfeld gewesen bevor auch sie auf
seinem sichtfeld getreten wäre unsere
analyse zeigt also alle fünf personen
hatten genug zeit und durch den
notausgang zu entkommen wenn der
notausgang offen gewesen ist
und sie das gewusst hätten dann hätten
sie alle den anschlag überleben können
sonstige tat seit dem anschlag haben die
angehörigen oft gesagt dass der
notausgang zu war und dass das alle in
der arena bar gewusst hätten sie
beklagen dass die staatsanwaltschaft
sagt dass nicht sicher sei ob sie hätten
überleben können wenn der notausgang
offen gewesen wäre und auch deswegen die
ermittlungen beendet hat das ist unserer
meinung nach ein gravierender fehler und
wir sind das die staatsanwaltschaft und
der untersuchungsausschuss der gerade
läuft das genau untersuchen sollten
die teams von forensic architektur- und
von frances betonen dass sie unabhängig
ermitteln und es ihnen wichtig sei
zivilgesellschaften in ihrem willen nach
aufklärung zu unterstützen
vor allem wenn es um staatliche gewalt
und rassismus geht
wir sind eine rechercheagentur
angesiedelt in der universität von
london wir haben uns vor zwölf jahren
gegründet es ist nicht der erste fall
aus hessen den wir behandeln vor sieben
jahren haben wir denn es rumort in
kassel untersucht ich spreche sicher für
mein gesamtes team wenn ich sage dass
dieser fall von hanau eine unserer
emotionalsten ermittlungen war
emotional ist an diesem tag auch arminen
coach der nicht verstehen kann dass die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittlungen ablehnt
unter anderem mit der begründung dass
unklar sei ob der notausgang in der
arena war verschlossen
in dem videomaterial dass die behörden
seit dem 20 februar 2020
zur verfügung haben ist ersichtlich dass
einige person vor der tat zum notausgang
gelaufen sind und
zurückkommen da dieser verschlossen ist
hier ist man so
beobachtet alles und ist sich
offensichtlich im klaren dass die tür
wieder einmal wie fast immer
verschlossen ist ich kann mir nicht
erklären wieso man dieses video material
nicht ausgewertet hat ist es inkompetenz
oder möchte man es nicht und was sagt
die staatsanwaltschaft hanau dazu sie
teilt uns mit dass man bei der
einstellung des ermittlungsverfahrens
zum notausgang bleibe weil weiter gelte
dass die verschluss verhältnisse in der
arena war nicht mit ausreichender
sicherheit aufgeklärt werden konnten
bei der zweiten tür in der ausstellungs
widors geht es um das theaterhaus
unsere ermittlungen zeigen dass die
polizei in hessen beim einsatz gegen
einen bewaffneten rechtsextremisten
fatale fehler begangen hat
fast zwei stunden lang haben die beamten
es versäumt das haus zu sichern
durch peter hätte fliehen können auch
der eingesetzte polizeihubschrauber
hätte das haus des täters überwachen
können
aber den piloten wurde die adresse nicht
mitgeteilt
obwohl sie der polizei bekannt war
wir haben mit unseren ermittlungen
gezeigt dass dieser polizeieinsatz in
mehreren hinsichten ein desaster war und
dass die polizei das leben der menschen
die in der umgebung waren in gefahr
gebracht hat es gab mehrere
möglichkeiten für den mörder aus seiner
haustür raus zu gehen und seine gewalt
fortzusetzen
wir haben die polizei südosthessen die
für hanno zuständig ist gefragt vor
allem zu den offenbar fehlenden
informationen im polizeihubschrauber
die antwort der polizei die in dem von
forensic architekt veröffentlichten
video zu hörenden tonaufzeichnungen sind
teil der ermittlungsergebnisse der
federführenden bundes behörden deshalb
die hessische polizei hierzu keine
stellungnahme abgeben kann
doch die generalbundesanwaltschaft und
das bka ermitteln dazu nicht teilen sie
uns schriftlich mit sie verweisen auf
den untersuchungsausschuss zum anschlag
in hanau der gerade in wiesbaden läuft
der wusste man von der initiative
neunzehnter februar sagt ihr fehle die
bringschuld des staates
die familien haben vor ein sieg
architekten beauftragt weil alle
anzeigen gegen die polizei gegen die
behörden ziemlich schnell
eingestellt wurden ist klar war es läuft
einfach nicht der staat kommt seine
aufgabe die sicherheitsbehörden kommen
seine aufgaben nicht nach und deshalb
mussten von annika kutscher ein
unabhängiges agentur beauftragt werden
um wirklich richtig ermittlungen
durchzuführen ja um zu zeigen was ist in
der tat macht passiert ja was hat die
polizei wer hat die polizei agiert was
hat die sfl gemacht was war bei dem
theaterhaus heute sind wir im
kunstverein und heute sehen wir neue
ergebnisse
die wünschen sich auch julia und
nicholas cooper
in frankfurt ist ein film zu sehen
dennoch mal erzählt dass ihr sohn willi
in der tatnacht mehrfach erfolglos
versuchte die polizei zu erreichen
nachdem er den täter mit seinem auto
hier oben rechts zu sehen verfolgt hatte
wie später herauskam war der notruf
unterbesetzt und das technische system
veraltet auf konsequenzen wartet familie
bis heute
[Musik]
vom kopf von politikern von polizisten
die dritte tür in der ausstellungs
widors ist die tür der zelle in der oury
jalloh 2005 verbrannte die polizei
behauptete der geflüchtete aus sierra
leone habe sich auf der matratze in
polizeigewahrsam angezündet seine
angehörigen kämpfen seit herum aufkleben
in frankfurt berichtete sein freund dass
sie auf eigene kosten zieht gutachten
und eine zweite autopsie beauftragten
dort hat man festgestellt dass wohl die
alu nasenbeinbruch hatte seiner trommel
alles kaputt war
zum schluss hat man das rausgekriegt
durch unser experte diesen
dass er ohne brandbeschleuniger geht
überhaupt nicht
forensic architektur hat in frankfurt
die zelle nummer fünf mit dem korridor
und den türen nachgebaut
die untersuchten rauch spuren deuten
nach ansicht des recherche teams darauf
hin dass die außentür während des feuers
die meiste zeit verschlossen war
die zellentür dagegen offen stand
das widerspricht der aussage eines
beamten der angegeben hatte dass er bei
seiner ankunft beide türen kurz
nacheinander geöffnet habe
seit 16 jahren kämpfen wir um die
wahrheit und gerechtigkeit
aber da ja dieser
systems verhindern
versucht die ganze zeit dieser sache zu
vertuschen
das finden wir sehr bedauerlich
zum abschluss sagte bahr dass er
persönlich fühle was die angehörigen von
herrn auf hüten sie alle fordern
aufklärung gerechtigkeit und
konsequenzen dem team von forensic
architekt sind sie sehr dankbar